i want to talk about the difference
between himalayan sea salt
and just regular sea salt is there a
difference
there is it's a big difference the great
majority of both of these have sodium
chloride
they both have trace minerals but
sea salt has microplastics
or nano amounts of plastic
in one study it showed that 90 percent
of
all the brands that were tested had
microplastics
however in himalayan sea salt
zero plastics why because of the
deposits that make up the himalayan salt
comes from an ancient sea before humans
before the pollution
now the problem with microplastics is
that it gets into our system it creates
inflammation
it creates a lot of problems because it
can act as an endocrine
disruptor and it does take a little bit
of time to degrade and break down
about 500 years so
what you need to do is limit your
exposure
to it so i do not recommend
consuming sea salt unless
it's celtic sea salt or it could be
pronounced
celtic this is okay this is from france
it's cleaner there's probably some
others that are fine too but
regular sea salt comes from the ocean
which is polluted
and chances are it will have
microplastics so you want to avoid that
now that then brings up the question
about table salt what about that
the majority of the population is just
consuming table salt they have no idea
that that
too has microplastics
no trace minerals just sodium chloride
it's bleached
some of the time they even add sugar to
it some of the time
and sometimes they add anti-caking agent
aluminum which is toxic to your brain
so what i'm trying to do is increase
your awareness and focus
in on a healthy salt because we need
salt
we needed to make hydrochloric acid in
our stomach to actually kill off
microbes
help us digest protein and assimilate
minerals
adrenals need a certain amount of salt
our immune system needs a certain amount
of salt
if we're low on salt the risk of getting
insulin resistance
goes up salt helps with hydration
also it's involved in the sodium
potassium pump
which is needed to power your muscles
and your nerves and give us energy
now how much salt do we need we need
between one and two
teaspoons depending on your activity
level how much you're sweating
but when you do keto you want to do at
least
one teaspoon if not a little bit more
each day
because of all the water weight that
you're losing and with the water weight
loss
comes a loss of electrolytes as well now
a couple things that you can do in
addition to
avoiding exposure to microplastics
because
it's in the water from the plastic
bottles that you're using and also the
canned water it's in a lot of different
things especially if you're using
microwaves with plastics and even
styrofoam
cups if you have good friendly bacteria
there's been some studies that show that
certain microbes in your microbiome can
help break down some of these plastics
number two consuming cruciferous food on
a regular basis
helps to dismantle and eliminate
endocrine disruptors
in general and also consuming enough
omega-3
has a tendency to keep your inflammation
down because one of the problems with
microplastics
is inflammation and so if you counter
that with taking things that keep your
inflammation low
you can minimize the damage to some
degree but definitely don't consume just
regular sea salt go with the himalayan
salt
or go with some other salts like celtic
salts that don't have micro plastics
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help